um
what was the question does she want to
get married she's okay with not uh i
think she does what about her family do
they like you her family yeah her
family's cool with me everyone in her
family so
her
her mom is great and then her uncle she
has an uncle his name is jerry t we call
puerto rican i know we call him gerardo
we call him tt jerry now tt jerry's an
interesting person because tt jerry who
is the god father i'm sorry godmother of
my of my
baby i'm gonna get to it my baby
daughter violet it's jasmine's jasmine's
uncle okay he's transgender oh so it's
so it's hi it's jasmine's godfather same
person but my daughter's godmother
because tt jerry was in prison for 20
years okay got locked up for a long time
recently got out of prison two years ago
and lives with us has become a part of
my life my whole world
fascinating individual um
he mar she says i was trans before it
was cool
back in the day trans that's what she
says she says she's a woman
she has she has she she has tits and a
dick that's what i'll put it i'll put it
there just you are a reality show can we
bring cameras into your home yes
that's it i'm telling you have you ever
picked me on the [ __ ] game show have
you
have you ever pitched yourself as a
reality show or yeah
cbs and then they flushed it down the
toilet yeah but they put me in cargo
pants that was the issue and also tt
jerry wasn't in my life yet so my ca
it's okay yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah thank you
reality show so tt jerry uh who by the
way uh tt jerry just uh got off
probation three weeks ago so i want to
say congrats to tt first time she's been
off probation since she's 18 years old
she's 57. shout her out yeah um shout
her out and and then immediately i'm
talking about the day she got on
probation the morning or probation
officer we had her on the speakerphone
was like you're off first time she was
crying whatever somebody tried to rob a
house on my corner and she ran after
them with a baseball bat i was like tt
you don't you're going to go right back
on probation let them rob the house let
them kill that family we're not but tt's
like a superhero tt doesn't care it's
like a marvel person here's the thing
with tt jerry okay ytt uh tito auntie
auntie and oh so and she's come on my
podcast many times ct jerry and on my
patreon patreon.com christy comedy we do
a thing tt jerry's bucket list where we
take tt and do things with her that she
couldn't do because she was incarcerated
for so long what was she incarcerated
for so she first went to jail uh in the
90s um for [ __ ] car theft you know
stealing they're stealing that oh
nothing not violent but in jail oh yeah
she got violent and and and because she
had to defend herself she says because
like she says she was she in a man's
prison or a woman she was in the tre
eventually first she was in the men's
prison because at that point when she
went in they didn't have all these
different they weren't woke yet prisons
weren't woke so now that prisons are
woke she went into the she served her
last years in the transgender section of
the prison which she said was balls of
[ __ ] and balls of balls so she
so she said
so she said um
so she told me um uh you know and and by
the way
fascinating person she served time with
son of sam
no yeah she she claims and and and
there's no way for us to verify but
other stories she has said have been
verified and other inmates that have
listened to the podcast um have messaged
me and be like they used to call her jlo
in prison they said everything jlo is
saying is true uh one of the guys she
wait tt's jenny from the block they call
it jenny from cellblock six yes in the
new york state prison system she's known
as jlo she's allegedly a legend in the
prison system but she's uh she admitted
uh and said you know very actually kind
things about him that she said she was
for for a little while for a couple of
months so she would she would happily
give son of sam [ __ ] in prison
happily yeah and she's beautiful
beautiful thing she said he's actually
united she said he's act she's a nice
guy you know the documentary the son of
sam documentary that came out on netflix
a couple years ago that kind of was
trying to say hey son of sam wasn't the
only killer that was like they pinned it
on son of sam he definitely killed
people but not everybody for those that
don't know that's young the younger
audience would know not that i have a
young audience but just he was a serial
killer around the uh i guess it was in
the second david berkowitz david
berkowitz yeah but
if he so that people did that jews
always went berkowitz and then other
people would take solace in going he was
adopted yeah so well here you go you
guys got david berkowitz we got john
wayne gacy the catholic's got gacy do we
who wins
i'd say john wayne gacy wins in that
fight we want to throw richard ramirez
in the night stalker now i don't know
but i would say but but all uh son of
sam would couples who were making out in
the park he'd shoot into the car and
kill him right which i told you what i
want so i guess if i was going to be
choosing to die i'd rather go sign a sam
just shoot me in the head i understand
you i seem to when i start talking to
you i think you're all over the place
but everything is like a circle circle
of life
yes wait and see but anyway let's
continue yes
see
[Music]
bye